>> Carla Hayden: Good morning.
>> Good morning.
>> Carla Hayden: And welcome
to the Library of Congress.
I'm Carla Hayden,
Librarian of Congress.
And today, we are commemorating
and celebrating two
important events.
One hundred and fifty
five years ago today,
President Abraham Lincoln
delivered the Gettysburg Address
in Gettysburg, Pennsylvania.
It was a very significant speech
and a very significant moment
in the history of this country.
And today, we are memorializing
this historic speech
by having the copy
of the address
that President Lincoln
brought with him
to the battlefield that day.
It's his reading copy.
And it is on display for
today in the Great Hall.
You can imagine that we
rarely, rarely take this item
out for public display
for conservation purposes.
So we're eager to show you
this important document.
To emphasize how rarely we take
it out and how important it is,
you may notice that we have
the capital police here.
So, enjoy looking at
it, and no sudden moves.
Now, and also today, the Library
of Congress is launching
a brand new initiative
that we are calling
By the People.
And it's a major crowdsourcing
project that we're hoping all
of you everywhere will help
us with, transcribing tens
of thousands of the
Library's collection online.
And we need your help.
In particular, transcribing
over 20,000 letters
to Abraham Lincoln.
And that's why it's
By the People.
So today, you may have noticed,
we have computers set up here
in the Great Hall to give
everyone a hands on experience
to dissect and transcribe
histories.
The Lincoln Letters will be
one of several collections
that you can help us transcribe.
We also will have
papers available
from Civil War soldiers.
The scouting reports of
baseball scout Branch Rickey,
who wrote about Henry
Aaron and Ernie Banks.
The papers, a Red Cross
founder, Clara Barton,
and of the Civil Rights
activist, Mary Church Terrell.
Now, we are live streaming
this morning's program
to encourage students like
the ones that are right here,
so we hope that you will be
the first on the computers.
That's why I asked you
to take your coats off.
To go public coast to coast.
And it's very easy.
Go to loc.gov and
start transcribing.
So, joining us today
are students
from several D.C. area schools.
And I know they want to
see the Gettysburg Address,
but also to help us record
and understand these letters.
So, would you give a shout
out when I call your school?
The Richard Wright Public
Charter High School.
[ Applause ]
Students from the Washington
Global Public Charter
Middle School.
[ Applause ]
Students from the Capitol Hill
Montessori Logan Middle School.
[ Applause ]
Now, and all of you
students here, please join us
in giving a really big
Washington shout out to students
from my home state,
Illinois, the Land of Lincoln.
Students from the Iles Middle
School in Springfield, Illinois.
Yay!
[ Applause ]
The students in Springfield,
Illinois, you should know,
and I spent summers
there every summer,
and they go to Lincoln's home,
they know all about Lincoln,
and so we're so glad that
they will be part of this.
So last month when the Library
launched a new strategic plan,
we wanted to make sure that
people, wherever they are,
could connect with the
Library of Congress.
And so I'd like to
introduce you to one
of the Library's most eminent
and celebrated experts
on history.
I can't think of a better person
to help us celebrate
President Lincoln
and the Gettysburg
Address than the person
who also helped historian Doris
Kearns Goodwin on the Team
of Rivals, our own
Michelle Krowl.
[ Applause ]
>> Michelle Krowl:
Wow, what a welcome.
After that, I was
wondering, wow,
who is that eminent
historian who's coming today?
For the next few minutes, it is
my privilege to provide a bit
of background and context
to Abraham Lincoln's
Gettysburg Address,
delivered 155 years ago today.
And it is altogether
fitting and proper
that we should be honoring
the Gettysburg Address
in this particular room, as the
mosaic above the doors leading
into the main reading
room include a quote
from the address.
Government of the people, by
the people, for the people.
So after we've done
this, you can turn around
and just look right behind you,
and that mosaic the woman has
in her lap that phrase.
It is July, 1863.
A tremendous battle
has just taken place in
and around the small
town of Gettysburg
in southern Pennsylvania.
The inhabitants of the town
number about 2,400 residents.
But during the three days
between July 1st and 3rd,
nearly 160,000 Union
and Confederate troops
fought on the nearby fields.
Fifty one thousand of
those men were casualties.
And of those, between 7
to 10,000 were killed
or mortally wounded.
Since both armies still relied
on animals to transport men
and material, 5,000 horses lay
dead on the battlefield as well.
And it was July, which
meant summer heat.
Something had to be
done immediately.
The fallen horses were
largely consumed by fire.
And unless taken home by loved
ones who travel to Gettysburg
to claim their soldiers, the
fallen men were hastily buried
on or near the battlefield.
That summer, talk in the
overwhelmed town turned
to creating a national
cemetery to reenter the bodies
of the Union soldiers
who died at Gettysburg.
Governor Andrew Curtin
of Pennsylvania appointed
Gettysburg lawyer David Wills
to lead a commission to
establish a new cemetery.
He approached the states whose
soldiers had fought and died
in the battle of Gettysburg
to contribute funds towards
the cost of purchasing
and improving land for a
cemetery and reentering the dead
from their temporary graves.
With financial pledges from
the participating states,
the commission purchased
17 acres adjacent
to the private Evergreen
Cemetery on the Cemetery Hill
that had seen so much action
during the battle in January.
Landscape architect William
Saunders designed the new
cemetery, which would ultimately
hold about 3,500 Union dead.
A memorial would anchor
the site and be surrounded
in semi circles by the graves
of the fallen Union soldiers.
He arranged the dead by state,
although the largest group
of the burials would
be the unknowns,
their identities
lost to history.
The rank of the soldier,
or his position
in life, made no difference.
All the gravesites and
markers were the same.
All were created equal.
Wills and the commission began
planning a dedication ceremony,
which required a
speaker of significance
and national prominence.
And if you think this is
where Abraham Lincoln enters
the story, you would be wrong.
The commission wanted Edward
Everett, who after a long
and distinguished career in
education and public service,
was one of the most
respected orators of the day.
Wills invited Everett to speak
at the dedication ceremony,
which was then set
for October 23rd.
But Everett was known for
long, carefully crafted,
and well researched
addresses, which he committed
to memory before delivering.
He couldn't possibly be
ready before November 19th.
So to accommodate
their star attraction
at the event, November
19th it was.
That's why we're celebrating
the Gettysburg Address today,
because of Edward Everett.
It is not clear when Abraham
Lincoln was first approached
about participating
in the dedication.
It might have been
as early as August,
with an informal word
from Governor Curtin.
The official request did
not come until November 2nd,
however, when David Wills wrote
Lincoln a short letter asking
him to deliver a few appropriate
remarks at the ceremony.
Just a few appropriate remarks.
Although busy preparing his
annual report to Congress,
and concerned about leaving
Washington while his young son
Tad was ill, Lincoln
agreed to participate.
The opportunity to honor the
Gettysburg dead and speak
to the nation about the
war outweighed his pressing
obligations at the White House.
Lincoln and his traveling party,
which included three
Cabinet secretaries
and several foreign dignitaries,
arrived in Gettysburg
by train on November 18th.
The next morning, the 19th,
the president and secretary
of state, William Seward,
visiting a battlefield,
an experience which exerted
a profound effect on Lincoln,
and one that may have
altered the course
of his address that afternoon.
Always reluctant to speak
extemporaneously, particularly
on important occasions, Lincoln
likely drafted his remarks
in Washington and carried the
document with him to Gettysburg.
The earliest known copy
of the Gettysburg Address is now
referred to as the Nicolay copy,
which we have on display
today in the Great Hall
of the Library of Congress.
And it's covered right now,
but you'll be able to see
if in just a little while.
If you're joining us remotely,
you can view the document online
in our online Abraham
Lincoln papers.
You will see that the first
page is written in pen
on Executive Mansion stationary.
But the second page is
written in pencil on a piece
of lined Foolscap paper,
equivalent to our
legal size paper today.
And at the bottom of the first
page in pencil are corrections
to form a somewhat
awkward textual bridge
between the two pages.
So, why the difference in the
paper and the writing medium?
Based on eyewitness accounts
and the document itself,
some historians speculate
that Lincoln's morning visit
to the battlefield inspired him
to alter the ending
of his address.
The portion in pen, written in
Washington, remained the same.
To change the ending,
Lincoln used the paper supply
and writing implement at hand,
a piece of torn Foolscap
and a pencil.
With a modified, but essentially
completed speech in hand,
Lincoln set off for the cemetery
about 10:00 in the morning.
The ceremony began at noon,
with appropriate music
and an invocation.
Edward Everett began reciting
his Gettysburg Address
soon after.
After harkening back to the days
of ancient Greece for precedence
for the occasion, Everett spend
the first hour narrating the
Battle of Gettysburg, only
five months in the past.
Then he argued against the
Rite of Succession claimed
by the Confederates, and mused
on an eventual reconciliation
of the two sides.
After almost two hours, Everett
Edwards' 13,000 word address
came to an end.
Remember those numbers.
President Lincoln followed
Everett at about 2:00 p.m.
and spoke approximately
272 words
that took roughly two
minutes to deliver.
Lincoln's role was only
to deliver a few
appropriate remarks.
And he consciously
kept his address brief.
But how significant
those few words were.
The speech itself progressed
through a three part
construction;
past, present and future.
Lincoln began by
invoking the past.
Four score and seven years
ago, our fathers brought forth,
upon this continent, a new
nation, conceived in liberty,
and dedicated to the proposition
that all men are created equal.
Although he respected the
rule of law established
in the U.S. Constitution,
President Lincoln revered
the ideals expressed
in the Declaration
of Independence.
Lincoln returned to the
declaration again and again
in his speeches and writings,
and firmly established
in the Gettysburg Address
that ideals of liberty
and equality formed the heart
of the national experiment
begun 87 years earlier in 1776.
So four score and
seven equals 87.
Lincoln then moved
to the present.
Now we are engaged in a great
Civil War, testing whether
that nation, or any
nation, so conceived
and so dedicated
can long endure.
Unlike Everett's long oration
on the Battle of Gettysburg,
Lincoln only referred in
passing to the battle,
noting that quote, "we are
met on a great battlefield
of that war for the purpose of
dedicating a cemetery to the men
who died, so," quote, "that
the nation might live."
He concluded with a
projection into the future.
The dead had already
consecrated the ground
with the blood and deeds.
Rather, it was up to the
living to honor that sacrifice
by dedicating themselves,
quote, "to the cause
for which they here gave the
last full measure of devotion."
The cause, as Lincoln saw
it, was quote, "a new birth
of freedom for the nation and
a determination that," quote,
"government of the people, by
the people, for the people,
shall not perish
from the Earth."
The war was a fight to save
the Democratic experiment
of self government that
the founders conceived,
and be reborn with a new
dedication to freedom.
What a new birth of freedom
entailed could be interpreted
in many ways.
Freedom from bondage for
the emancipated slaves,
freedom for the nation from
the institution of slavery,
freedom for the union to
march, to march toward progress
after having survived
the test of Civil War.
And beyond national borders,
a new birth of freedom
in America could inspire
other Democratic experiments
around the world.
In December, 1862, Lincoln
referred to the union
as the last best hope
on Earth, of Earth.
And that still held
true in 1863.
But the nation needed reminding
of that larger context.
The war was in its third
year in November, 1863.
And with no end in sight,
war weariness and doubts
about the war had set in.
Emancipation remained
unpopular in much of the north.
In fact, just a week after
the Battle of Gettysburg,
destructive draft
riots against the war
and emancipation
ignited in New York City.
With his words at Gettysburg,
Lincoln reminded the country
of the principles for which
the soldiers fought and died.
And how did Americans respond?
I know this will be hard
to imagine, but newspapers
and media openly aligned with
one political party or another.
An editorial opinion largely
followed the party line.
The Springfield Republican
in Massachusetts thought his
little speech is a perfect gem.
The Patriot and Union in
Harrisburg, Pennsylvania,
on the other hand,
called the text
of the address silly remarks.
And that, quote, "the veil
of oblivion shall be dropped
over them, and that they
shall be no more reposted
or thought of."
Well, the Patriot later
issued a retraction
to that editorial,
however, in 2013.
Better late than never.
But the renowned
orator for whom the date
of the ceremony had been changed
immediately recognized the
significance of Lincoln's
few appropriate remarks.
The next day, Edward Everett
wrote to Lincoln with praise.
"I should be glad if I could
flatter myself that I came
as near to the central idea
of the occasion in two hours
as you did in two minutes."
I think most of us would
agree with Everett Edwards',
Edward Everett's assessment.
Today, of course, the
Gettysburg Address is one
of the most admired speeches
in the English language.
The phrases four score and
seven years ago, little note,
nor long remember,
altogether fitting and proper,
a new birth of freedom, the
last full measure of devotion,
and of the people,
by the people,
for the people are
instantly recognizable.
But you might be
surprised to learn that even
for such an iconic, there are
still many questions we cannot
definitively answer, due to
absent or conflicting evidence.
As a Lincoln scholar once wrote,
touch any aspect of the address,
and you touch a mystery.
For example, presuming
there was a second sheet
on Executive Mansion stationary
in that original
draft, what did it say?
We don't know.
How different would that
first ending have been?
We don't know.
Did Lincoln read the
address on stage?
Did he memorize it?
Or both? Conflicting evidence.
Was the addition of
the phrase under God,
as recorded in the newspapers,
an improvised addition
at the time, or was there yet
another manuscript provided
to reporters on the scene
that contained that phrase?
Did the audience applaud
during the speech,
as some newspaper
accounts record?
Or did they remain
respectfully silent throughout?
It's important to remember
that on November 19th, 1863,
the audience didn't
know they were listening
to a two minute address
that would become one
of the world's most treasured
texts, and would be the subject
of fascination and study
for generations to come.
What we do know for certain
is that words contained
in historic documents
have power.
They have the power to
inform us, entertain us,
enrage us, inspire us.
They tell us who we have been
in the past, how we became
who we are in the present, and
who we could be in the future.
They are worth preserving and
exploring so that the history
of the people, by the people,
for the people shall not
perish from the Earth.
And now to read the
text of the Nicolay copy
of the Gettysburg Address
is Christian Melgar.
Currently a senior at Rockville
High School in Rockville,
Maryland, Christian is enrolled
in the International
Baccalaureate Program
at his school.
He plans to attend college
where he will major either
in early childhood education,
or proceed with a bachelor's
of science in biology.
Or hopefully maybe do
both at some point.
He has been acting
in his school plays
and musicals for six years.
On top of living a normal
teenaged life, he has a job
at the Barrie School
in Maryland,
where he is a camp counselor,
and an extended day employee.
When Christian isn't working
with children or at school,
he enjoys going on nature walks
with his two adorable
little nieces.
Christian has always
valued education,
and has taken advantage of
it, much like Abraham Lincoln,
whose stirring words
Christian will now read.
So please welcome
Christian Melgar.
[ Applause ]
>> Christian Melgar: I'd first
like to welcome, or thank,
the Library of Congress.
It's an honor and both a
pleasure to have invited me.
Four score and seven years
ago, our fathers brought forth,
upon this continent, a new
nation, conceived in liberty,
and dedicated to the proposition
that all men are created equal.
Now we are engaged in a great
civil war, testing whether
that nation, or any nation so
conceived, can long endure.
We are met on a great
battlefield of that war,
and we have come to
dedicate a portion of it,
as a final resting place
to those who died here,
and that the nation might live.
This we may, in all
propriety, do.
But, in a larger sense,
we cannot dedicate
we cannot consecrate,
we cannot hallow this ground.
The brave men, living and
dead, who struggled here,
have hallowed it, far above our
poor power to add or detract.
The world will little note, nor
long remember what we say here;
while it can remember
what they did here.
It is rather for us, the
living, to stand here,
we here be dedicated to the
great task remaining before us,
that from these honored dead,
we take increased devotion
to that cause in which they
here gave the last full measure
of devotion, that we here highly
resolve these dead shall not
have died in vain; that the
nation shall have a new birth
of freedom, and that the
government of the people,
by the people, for the people,
shall not perish from the earth.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Meghan Ferriter:
Hi, everyone.
My name is Meghan Ferriter.
I know that you are
really anxious
to see the Gettysburg
Address draft,
and also to start transcribing.
And thank you for
being here today.
I just want to share a few
details about our program,
why we're taking this approach,
and also what's going
to happen today.
So, you've just learned
about the Nicolay copy
of the Gettysburg Address,
and other documents.
But did you know the Library of
Congress holds letters, diaries,
reports, and many other
materials, as well?
Well, it's true.
It's a variable treasure trove.
And if you get the
opportunity to see them,
you should always
take the opportunity.
Today, we are working together
to complete transcriptions
of letters that people wrote
to Abraham Lincoln
during his career.
And when we say work
together, we mean we're going
to work together in this
room, but also people who are
around the country, and
possibly around the world.
If we work together to do
this, we can join Dr. Hayden
and the Library of Congress
to make these treasures
more accessible, readable,
and legible to many
different audiences.
So whether that is our
people who are visiting
for the first time online,
or they're doing research,
or they're just a little bit
curious and want to learn more.
So, as you know, we've
already shared some
of these versions online.
For example, Michelle mentioned
that the Nicolay copy is
visible online already.
But some of these documents
are not keyword searchable.
So that would mean you would
have to come find a page
and read through
the entire thing
to find what you're looking for.
So what we're trying to do is
create transcriptions or text
that lets these things
be keyword searchable.
So, that's a little
bit of the why.
Let's talk about the how.
So, today, if you're
with us in person,
we're going to take a couple
of different approaches.
So if you're one of the
student groups who's with us,
we're going to move you
through some stations.
There are also other stations
that are available for those
of you who are visiting
today and are not
with a student group, to try
your hand at transcribing.
We have also some
handwriting activities
that are a little bit
further back here.
So really quickly, if you're
watching on the live stream,
or even if you're
here in person,
here are the ways you're
going to get started.
The first thing you can do
is look on the home page
and click the blue Let's
Go button, which is going
to take you to a page
that needs some help.
You can also find a project
by clicking on campaigns
and selecting a project.
We're recommending that
you start in the years,
in the Letter to
Lincoln's campaign,
and also in the years
1860, 1861, and 1862.
So once you're in a letter,
you're going to see an image
of the letter on the left
hand side of the page,
and a transcription field
on the right hand side.
And you can zoom in on the
image, you can turn it,
you can drag the screen
so you can see the letter
on a little bit more largely.
And then you'll begin
typing in the field
on the right hand side.
There are also quick tips
to help you get started.
And we have a really
robust help center,
and we would love your feedback
to make that even better.
So, a few last tips to
help you get started.
One thing to keep in mind is
that we have thousands
of pages available.
So there's something
for everyone.
If you find a page that looks
too challenging or complicated,
or you just really think
that there's a better story
on the next page, that's fine.
You can find a new
page and get started.
We recommend that you try
reading a letter first.
Sometimes by reading,
you can get a sense
of what handwriting was like
and how people corresponded
in the 19th century.
You can find directions
in the help center.
You can use the help tab
that's at the top of each page.
You also, if you're ready
to start transcribing,
can take it slowly and read the
words that are on either side.
And sometimes the context
of words helps make
things make more sense.
Excuse me.
Another thing that we're
asking is have fun.
It's not a test.
So if you have some questions,
you want to find
some information,
or you're not really sure,
you can ask anybody
else who's around you.
If you are online and you're
watching, you can share
on Twitter or on History Hub.
We also want you to
contribute as much
as you or as little as like.
So if you have only done a few
words, you can save that page
and send it on for
someone else to work on.
So, one last pro tip.
You can transcribe
without an account.
If you're at any of the stations
today, we've logged you in,
so you can try tagging as well.
And we want to say thank
you for being here.
And if you're watching
from afar, you can join
in on Twitter or on History Hub.
You can send questions to
at crowd underscore loc.
Or send us an e mail at
crowd dot loc dot gov.
We'd love to hear more
about what you learn
and what you think about
this program By the People.
And you can also find it
at crowd dot loc dot gov.
My colleagues and I
are here to help you,
and we're really looking forward
to spending time with you today.
But right now, I'd
like to ask Dr. Hayden
to share something
very special with you.
>> Carla Hayden:
Thank you, Meghan.
I'm eager to jump on
one of those computers.
I have my glasses.
For those of you
of a certain age,
you know that's what we need to.
And before we do that, and
I'm going to have Meghan
and Christian and
Michelle join me
to present the Gettysburg
Address to you of great reveal.
I want you to think
about the fact, though,
that what you're doing,
in helping us transcribe
these letters,
is bringing to life the letters
and the thoughts of people
from decades and centuries
ago, people from 1860 that felt
so strongly that they wanted
to write letters
to Abraham Lincoln.
And what you're doing, and
what you can help us do,
is bring those thoughts
to life in this age.
So, thank you.
Thank you for doing that.
So, now, I think we're
going to pull the cover off.
And if the young
people could help us,
we're going to count down.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Five, four, three, two, one.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible ]